we have a major story today to lead with
and it sort of goes directly to possible
crimes committed by President Donald
Trump and his campaign but it also goes
to corporate media effectively falling
hook line & sinker for what was clearly
a calculated decision that was made and
this all relates to the sum of a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars which was
paid to adult film actress stormy
Daniels by Trump's personal attorney
Michael Cohen and to give you the
15-second reset on the story Donald
Trump allegedly had an affair with
stormy Daniels years ago close to
Election Day 2016 she was paid a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars in hush
money
she was also asked to sign a
nondisclosure agreement and the story
that we've been told so far is that the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars came
not from Donald Trump nor from Donald
Trump's campaign which would potentially
be illegal but from Michael Cohen
Trump's lawyer personally and that
Donald Trump neither knew about the
payment nor the non-disclosure agreement
nor did he ever repay Michael Cohen the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars this
was unbelievable from day one right
first and foremost because Donald
Trump's name is on the non-disclosure
agreement Trump didn't sign it but in
principle how can people be parties to
contracts they don't know exists doesn't
really make any sense and in addition to
that it was always hard to believe that
the hundred and thirty thousand dollars
which Michael Cohen had to mortgage his
house to obtain were never returned to
him by the billionaire Donald Trump it
always seemed like a legal and PR
manipulation to claim that Cohen paid
the money just out of the goodness of
his heart out of love for Donald Trump
as Michael Cohen's attorney said to
megyn kelly a few weeks ago well in
comes Rudy Giuliani former New York City
Mayor one of the latest additions to
Donald Trump's legal team which is a
legal team that's been constantly in
flux since it was put together and
Giuliani goes on Fox News last night and
he says oh yeah a Donald Trump did pay
Michael Cohen back for the hundred and
thirty thousand dollars which obviously
contradicts the idea that Trump didn't
know about the payment
it obviously contradicts the idea that
Donald Trump didn't pay Michael Cohen
back which is what we were told and
hypothetically it means that there could
have been a crime depending on whether
the source of that money was Donald
Trump personally or the Trump campaign
but it also potentially eliminates some
other crimes so let's get to the video
clip here is Rudy Giuliani on Fox News
last night I was talking about the
hundred thirty thousand dollar payment
right the settlement payment which is a
very regular thing for lawyers to do the
question there was the only possible
violation there would be was it a
campaign finance violation but usually
were result in a fine by the way not
this big storm of storm troopers coming
in and breaking down his apartment and
breaking out his office that was money
that was paid by by his lawyer the way I
would do out of his law firm funds or
whatever funds doesn't matter the
president reimbursed that over a period
of setting me it said didn't I will
think Lehrer that he did it on his own
he did without asking look I don't know
I haven't investigated that no reason to
dispute that no reason is for the
recollection I like Michael a lot you
like Michael oh yeah I feel very bad
he's been victimized like this the
president feels even worse by the way
again Sean Hannity saying he's known Co
in a while without mentioning he
actually worked with Michael Cohen but
let that's that's not even gonna that's
not gonna rate today Rudy Giuliani after
this interview told the New York Times
that this isn't just something he's
saying but that he has documents which
show that Donald Trump did make this
payment so the obvious question is why
admit this all along Trump claimed that
he didn't pay him back didn't know about
it seems like an unforced error right
wrong this is a calculation much like
the calculation with Russia collusion
remember there was no collusion shifted
into a narrative of if there was
collusion it wouldn't be a crime and it
wouldn't be illegal anyway among some
right and here they are obviously
calculating it's better for them to
shift from there was no repayment to
repayments for settlements are totally
normal obviously any client is going to
repay their lawyer for a settlement that
was made and part of the calculation is
the
trumpets want care that Trump directly
lied about this it is not a slight
distortion it's a straight-up lie right
let's be super clear Trump was asked
specifically aboard Air Force One last
month did you know about the payment to
stormy Daniels and Donald Trump said no
and said talk to Michael Cohen he was
then asked do you know where he got the
money to make that payment and Donald
Trump said no I don't know rather than
well yeah he got it from me because I
paid him back
Giuliani isn't stupid he is a hyper
partisan guy he has said a lot of things
that don't make a lot of sense but he's
not stupid and clearly there's been a
determination made here that the legal
danger is bigger if Trump doesn't repay
if Tom Trump didn't repay Cohen because
that would potentially raise more legal
issues than the idea that hey this is
just a client paying back their lawyer
it was alone it was a prepaid settlement
money whatever right as long as Trump
didn't pull the money from his campaign
fund it wouldn't be illegal and the
calculation that was made and I believe
it was accurately made is that framing
Trump as a liar is the best thing here
because he's never been held to account
by his supporters for lying all the time
about everything what's just one more
lie right and then now the next step in
this is Trump tweeting and shifting the
story again saying it wasn't even really
a repayment specifically for the hundred
and thirty thousand dollars Trump just
regularly paid retainers to his attorney
Michael Cohen this is actually genius
check out this series of three tweets
this morning where Donald Trump said mr.
Cohen an attorney received a monthly
retainer not from the campaign and
having nothing to do with the campaign
from which he entered into through
reimbursement a private contract between
two parties known as a non-disclosure
agreement or NDA these agreements are
very common among celebrities and people
of wealth in this case it is in full
force and effect and will be used in
arbitration for damages against Miz
Clifford Daniels the agreement was used
to stop the false and extortionist
accusations made by her about an affair
despite already having signed a detailed
letter admitting there was no affair
prior to its validation by Ms Clifford
and her attorney this was a private
agreement money from the
campaign or contributions played no role
ro ll by the way instead of ro le in
this transaction America 2018 make
America great again this is where we are
now and this is a you know when Drudge
Report has this for hours as their main
story it's not a mistake by Giuliani
it's a calculation and corporate media
has fallen all over themselves to report
it as a major unforced error which I
just simply don't believe it is the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership